it's Thursday September 15th I'm Rob
with the Daily News this week's
beginning to close but the news is
flooding so let's open up those gates
and take a look if you were one of the
three million people who played the
resident evil 7 demo congrats you just
broke a new record the resident evil 7
demo called beginning our is the most
downloaded single-player ps4 demo the
demo was released last June and even
though it's said to be a prologue it
features a different protagonist and
will not be in the full resident evil 7
game and if you were a fan of the demo
good news a new version of the demo
called Twilight is out now the demo
allows players to explore more of the
mysterious derelict mansion even more
good news the demo does not require a PS
Plus membership score and in other
pre-release video game record breakers
the battlefield 1 beta just made one of
its own EA Games announced today that
it's battlefield 1 beta which ended last
week Holden over 13 million players
setting the mark as the biggest beta in
the history of Electronic Arts the
previous title holder went to Star Wars
Battlefront beta which had more than 9
million players EA also released an
infographic that pertained to the beta
achievements for example 60 2.2 million
horseback Hills 13.8 million people got
run over by cars and additionally the
most popular class was assault was
pulled in thirty percent of players
followed by the Scout at twenty-eight
percent senior producer alex grande will
thank fans and said the team at dice is
poring over all the data and will tune
the game accordingly for example the
light tank performed a little too well
he said suggesting a nerf is incoming I
can agree with that it was fun while it
lasted
oh the Bioshock collection is out this
week making it a great time to relive
the series but it also brings up the
question why can't we have more Rolling
Stones glick cyl today published an
in-depth interview with the Bioshock
designer ken Levine in which he explains
exactly why he stopped making Bioshock
games regarding BioShock Infinite Levine
said it changed my life in terms of what
it did to my health and what it did to
my view of making games and my
relationships with people Levine said he
is a creative type who would rather
write stories than manage people in
particular after making BioShock
Infinite Levine and a small team left
irrational games and are currently
working on a small scale open-world game
it's been an unfortunate trend lately
for video games getting delayed and it
seems like South Park the fractured
butthole will do the same the game was
originally slotted to come out this
December but now it's set to release in
q1 of early 2017 meaning sometime
between january and march ubisoft stated
in a blog post the development team
wants to make sure the game experience
meets the high expectations of fans and
the additional time will help them
achieve this goal it's an unfortunate
delay but you can admire their choice to
finance the game rather than follow suit
of the South Park show's creators and
rush to meet their deadline well that's
all the news I got for you today as well
as the week like my hearty takes over
tomorrow and then next week just takes
back the reins thanks for watching and
have a happy Thursday
you